[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo
ante la situación de kobe 19 ahora
trabajamos desde casa a un año de
terminar su mandato en chile el
presidente sebastián piñera entregó un
inesperado anuncio dará carácter de
urgencia al proyecto de matrimonio
igualitario que se discute en el
congreso de un país reconocido por su
conservadurismo la decisión generó todo
tipo de reacciones desde el júbilo hasta
el rechazo y las redes sociales fueron
un gran escenario de discusión que dice
la sociedad chilena empezamos
el presidente chileno sebastián piñera
dio a conocer que daría urgencia a la
tramitación del proyecto de ley de
matrimonio igualitario en el país un
anuncio sorpresivo no solo porque viene
de un mandatario o conservador y
católico sino porque se trata de un
proyecto que lleva discutiéndose en el
congreso desde 2017 después de que fuera
enviado allí por la ex presidenta
michelle bachelet y que no ha avanzado
ante lo que la ciudadanía denuncia como
falta de voluntad política desde 2015
las parejas del mismo sexo en chile-
sólo pueden contraer un acuerdo de unión
civil pero no se reconoce como
matrimonio si el proyecto firmado por
bachelet se aprueba el país se
convertiría en el octavo de américa
latina en reconocer este derecho luego
de que lo hicieran costa rica colombia
brasil ecuador uruguay argentina y
algunos territorios de mexico
la decisión de piñera generó divisiones
entre su coalición integrada por
partidos de derecha y centroderecha y
desde donde dijeron sentirse
traicionados entre personas y
organizaciones defensoras de derechos
humanos que apoyan la causa del fbi hubo
júbilo pero también descontento por lo
que denuncian como demoras e
incumplimiento del ejecutivo con sus
compromisos ahora sigue presionando para
que el proyecto sea aprobado en redes
sociales los usuarios publicaron
capturas de pantalla de medios de
comunicación que registraron en el
pasado como piñera se mostraba en
desacuerdo con el matrimonio igualitario
y por ello señalaron que su aparente
nueva postura es un acto de oportunismo
e incluso dijeron que se trataba de una
cortina de humo para desviar la atención
de temas coyunturales como las graves
violaciones a los derechos humanos
denunciados durante el estallido social
de 2019 otros calificaron la decisión de
piñera como una campaña de ping washing
que en español podría traducirse como
lavado rosa es un término que se refiere
a la estrategia que utilizan empresas
países y políticos para mostrarse como
simpatizantes del movimiento del gti y
mejorar su imagen cuando en realidad no
les
a la causa
estos señalamientos de oportunismo
contra sebastián piñera en internet
vienen también acompañados de imágenes
de la ex presidenta michelle bachelet a
quien un gran número de usuarios le
atribuyen el hecho de que el proyecto
haya llegado al congreso pero además ha
salido a relucir un antiguo vídeo en el
que la ex mandataria se mostraba en
desacuerdo con el matrimonio igualitario
antes de llegar a la presidencia y
aunque para algunos se trata de una
falta de coherencia otros lo tomaron
como un ejemplo para defender el derecho
a cambiar de opinión en medio de la
discusión los chilenos han recordado que
el proyecto sobre el matrimonio
igualitario no fue una iniciativa
política sino el resultado de un acuerdo
entre el gobierno y el movimiento de
integración y liberación homosexual
movilh que demandó al ejecutivo ante la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos así nos lo explica óscar
rementería vocero de esta organización
tres parejas chilenas contrajeron es el
matrimonio igualitario en otros países
al llegar a chile trataron de
inscribirlo en el registro civil que es
la institución la agencia pública que
registra los matrimonios en nuestro país
y esta institución se negó diciendo que
no tenía las atribuciones legales para
hacerlo esta situación fue denunciada
nuestra organización y nosotros
presentamos las acciones judiciales en
los tribunales nacionales por
discriminación en este caso al no
reconocer el vínculo matrimonial que
habían contraído estas parejas chilenas
del mismo sexo en el extranjero en
contraposición a lo que pueden hacer
parejas de distinto sexo que se han
casado en otros países que pueden
inscribir este matrimonio es un problema
en el registro civil llegando hasta la
corte suprema tribunal constitucional y
seguimos en tribunales internacionales y
por eso se llegó este proceso de
mediación amistosa en esa época el
gobierno de la presidenta bachelet como
se dice en términos jurídicos se allanó
es decir reconoció todo lo que nosotros
estábamos denunciando y se comprometió a
subsanar lo entre ellos el envío del
proyecto de ley de matrimonio
igualitario se realizaron muchas mesas
de conversación muchas organizaciones de
la diversidad entregaron sus aportes y a
partir de éstos
el gobierno confecciona un proyecto de
ley bastante completo bastante integral
que fue el que se envió al parlamento el
año 2017 y que el presidente piñera
anunció que aplicaría esta justicia
legislativa los medios de comunicación
chilenos han cubierto las noticias
resaltando las razones que llevaron al
presidente a tomar esta decisión y los
efectos que ha provocado el portal el
mostrador dice matrimonio homosexual la
bomba igualitaria con la que el
presidente piñera hizo detonar el
corazón conservador de chile vamos
refiriéndose a su coalición el medio
independiente interferencia titula
piñera apuesta a cambiar la agenda con
matrimonio igualitario pero sólo
complica a su sector radio adn consultó
la opinión de un analista y titula que
la decisión de piñera sobre el
matrimonio igualitario fue un intento
desesperado por marcar una diferencia
el noticiero teletrece recogió una frase
de una entrevista hecha al mandatario en
la que éste defendió el proyecto
he ido evolucionando como lo han hecho
tantas personas dijo piñera mientras que
otros periódicos de américa latina'
titular con la frase que utilizó el
presidente para
anunciar su respaldo al proyecto de ley
ha llegado el tiempo del matrimonio
igualitario en nuestro país
y a propósito del matrimonio igualitario
despedimos esta emisión de revista
digital con las imágenes que han
inundado las redes sociales con motivo
del inicio del mes del orgullo lgtb de
internet se ha llenado de arco iris y
mensajes con los que los usuarios no
sólo conmemoran las luchas de esta
comunidad sino que buscan crear
conciencia sobre sus derechos y arrojar
luz sobre las dificultades que aún
faltan por resolver
hasta aquí revista digital recuerda que
si quieres repetir esta u otra emisión
de nuestro programa lo puedes hacer a
través de nuestra página web www puntos
francia 24 punto com
[Música]